Thoughts on photodynamic therapy depends on what you're describing as photodynamic therapy.
Photodynamic therapy is described by the Mexico Cancer Thetics as the use of the laser lights
internally and with a medication. We've had a few people do it. Very mixed results. I don't know
really giant parades on photodynamic therapy. There is photodynamic therapy loosely. There's clinics
that are loosely using that term when they're using a light therapy. So you red light therapy,
it's photodynamic therapy. Well, I guess technically it is, but that's not really how Mexico Cancer
Thetics are describing it. It's totally different. Use of lasers. That photodynamic therapy, well,
technically, but that's not really how they're doing it for the Mexico Cancer Thetics. You
can't legally do photodynamic therapy wire up and wire the way they do it in the Mexico Cancer
Thetics. I don't believe you could do it in the US.